How do we measure “good”? Is it defined
by the majority? Is it measured by self-satisfaction
or personal fulfillment?
The good of any thing
is found in its ability to accomplish what
it was created for, to realize its purpose
for existence as intended by its maker.
Only in this realization can something truly be
called “good.” “The good” is possible
only in the light of truth. Not truth as it
is often defined today, by personal preference
or popular consensus, but truth as it is…independent
from opinions and emotions. And where goodness
and truth exist, there you will find beauty.
We were created for a purpose. Our purpose
is not left to chance or whim, but was determined
by our Maker and written in our nature. Our
purpose is to seek truth, in order to discover
and to act on what is good and beautiful in
this life.